so that's uh that's another issue I'm
just ticking off all the issues that
we've solved here so far we get that
we're gonna finish the world here Mike
Baker yeah
with that North Korean release of those
prisoners that's a good thing that's a
good end I think both Trump and pence I
think of going out the Andrews Air Force
Base to meet them as they come in
Wow and you know but it will be you'll
be interesting to see look it wasn't it
I think was an easy give for Kim jong-un
to do and what were they over there
imprisoned for mmm well one of them what
I'm was a businessman and he was serving
10 years hard labor imagine hard labor
camp in North Korea for supposedly for
espionage he's a business guy and they
don't care I mean they've done this
numerous times in the past it really
doesn't matter if you show up and you're
in business
the other two were also interesting they
were academics they were at the
Pyongyang University for science and
technology both of them were teaching
there which is manof where I got my
degree and my undergrad degree Pyongyang
University I went there for the sports
[Laughter]
and and I worked during the year as the
mat it's a Pyongyang missiles like a guy
dressed as a missile remember where I
was going with this story and so I just
like rambling until I get my head
straight I'm like that deer in that
video so those two were were again the
same thing supposedly engaged in
espionage and so they got chucked in so
we'll see I mean I you know whether
whether we're able to get anything from
this who knows but that's a good sign
the fact that he met with as you pointed
out president moon from South Korea a
very good sign the Chinese have they
sent their foreign minister over to
Pyongyang a couple weeks ago first time
foreign ministers been over there and
maybe 11 years 12 years Wow so they
understand the importance of this and I
think everybody's the dynamic is shifted
because I think you know we've kicked
the can down the road for so long that
they're basically at the point where
their programs or you don't close to
being fully them
and I think that you know the Chinese
understand that that means that all
those other options perhaps of kicking
the can down the road aren't on the
decision tree anymore and so you know
they don't want chaos on the peninsula
they don't want military conflict nobody
does and so I think the Chinese for
basically the first time have been
aggressively assisting with the
sanctions that were put in place mmm
that had a very quick response on Kim
jong-un he's not suicidal he just wants
to survive in position of leadership
right so he's looking at it thinking
okay the calculus has changed so I got
to do something different and again you
know being pragmatic maybe it doesn't
work but at least we're trying and I
think that's a good thing
so no unquestionably it's a good thing
and also the video that North Korean
soldier fleeing and getting shot shot at
as he escapes North Korea I mean that
had to get to North Korea too and they
realize like Jesus Christ is a second
guy and how many months that was fleeing
like that and and got away and they're
finding parasites in their body and yeah
extreme malnourished and this is a
soldier so you got to think everybody
over there is probably in an entire
straight right and I've talked about
this in terms of just just a simple if
not simple but the idea that you know
the population in terms of its physical
stature compared to the South Koreans is
you know they're shorter they're there
and that's how nutrition issue I think
also I think they've realized that
there's only so much they can do going
forward to lock the place down all right
and technology at some point even though
it's North Korea and there's not a lot
there there's enough and I think there's
a sense that they you know how long
thinking they can control the population
the way they have so again he's not the
Kim is not suicidal he wants to maintain
power when you think about every country
action its own best interest or every
leader acts in their own best interest
that's his thought process and and how
do I do that well okay you know maybe so
I think that you know it could happen we
could get something really good out of
this we'll see